Hello, my name is Nick Gustafson, and
I'm a data scientist at Udacity. My background
is I did my undergrad in neurobiology and
I went on in graduate school to continue
studying neurobiology, and neuroscience in particular, and
kind of, computational neuroscience and looking at algorithmic
And all mechanisms of learning and decision making.
And while towards that, hm, tail end of
my graduate work I, eventually kind of realized I did not want to stay
in academia, however I still have this
kind of strong passion for analyzing data,
modeling data, understanding You know, patterns within
it, and kind of, you know, applying
scientific methods, and data science just, just
felt like a natural progression from there.